hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video today is Thursday it is the dev
stream recap I haven't done one these in
a couple of weeks the crit the devs are
off on Christmas leave I'm finally great
to be back and finally making these
amazing videos that I love making for
you guys we had tons of new info today
new partial game mode in the event
playlist new effect and tons of in or
not tons of information a little bit of
a tease of information of year two with
more to come the following dead stream
so let's get started so one thing before
we start I just want to mention if the
gameplay is looped at one point I do
apologize and if it's a bit laggy I also
do apologize I'm in my new setup at the
moment so hopefully the mic does sound
as good as it was before maybe better or
maybe worse who knows
but that's why I'm recording my xbox
gameplay on PC in it there's a little
bit of a lag issue I'm going to be fixed
fixing that hopefully before the stream
on Saturday but if that's there and if
the game plays Luke I'm sorry I didn't
have enough time to get more everything
will be back to normal next week I
promise but first the start off is the
new event mode it's called dance of
death it is a 2v2 mode and it says to
win the battle both enemies have to be
dead at the same time otherwise they
respawn killing an enemy adds an extra
second to their respawn time and it's
available January 18th which is next
week so you're going to have to work
with your team or your teammate and
hopefully that you can kill both of them
at the exact same time and may I'm
assuming it doesn't have to be exact
maybe you would like I said a second or
two of a little bit of a brief period
but once again they have to die very
quickly like in similar or it gets reset
next up there is a discount on mythic
outfits this week they're gonna be
10,000 steel instead of 15 so you might
want to grab those very quickly if
you're thinking about getting a mythic
offer for a new character is discounted
by 5 K steel so definitely hop on that
and as well congrats to the Vikings for
hitting or for winning round 4 and
becoming the season 4 faction war
winners you guys are gonna get your
awards at the end of the season and
that's about it
we have no news on what they're going to
be we'll find out when it gets to that
point as well we also have a new rainbow
effect that's going to be the new effect
there's a little bit of a rainbow and
it's going to be for all the heroes in
our shoulder video right now
[Music]
[Music]
so that was cool a little bit of a nice
twist uh some of the people like their
realistic version of 400 you're going to
absolutely hate this for the people that
don't really care hey there's another
new effect for you next up we're gonna
be talking about a few of the teases for
season five number going to go into next
week's patch buffer see but for the
plains of season five and this is my
Cummins a little bit of surprise there's
gonna be no new heroes for season five
it's going to probably be similar to
what Rainbow six did with Operation
health where if and none of you don't
know they basically didn't add new
heroes and they basically focused on
fixing the game for that entire season
but they did come next season with an
extra hero so possibly during season six
we're gonna be eating three heroes
instead of two but who knows but for
season five we get no heroes they're
gonna be focusing on hero changes and
reworks like Ken say Berserker conqueror
Highlander this season parry changes
dedicated servers coming to season five
lag compensation and the usual new
content and events like every week
apparently who's going to be more
details next dev stream so definitely
stick around on this channel for the
next week recap and I will keep you all
up to date and then that's about it for
season 4 season 5 we don't exactly know
just yet once I said like I said next
week we'll know tons of more information
but next up we have next week's patch
which is coming out Thursday January
18th and there's going to be tons of bug
fixes fixes many of the instances from
flicker and saw feints fixed an issue
that a lot of players on an extremely
short reaction window to dodged out of
certain death situations when thrown off
of ledges and also I like to point out
that I will have these patch notes in
the description if you do want to follow
along and read all of them these are
basically the main points shaman is
going to be getting a little bit of a
rework remove super armor from the first
100 milliseconds of her pounce while
recovering from shamans pounce you can
activate orange 300 milliseconds earlier
than normal or 500 milliseconds earlier
after being hit by a attack and then
fixed her pounce tracking snapping to
players if it impacted at the same time
as the bleed tick are moosh is getting a
little bit of a rework he gets 5 extra
damage on several of his attacks he
cannot be gb2 out of a out of a light
attack anymore and you are now
guaranteed a top heavy from guard bricks
are emotions getting a little bit of a
buff shamans getting a little bit of a
minor nerf I'm not entirely sure how
these are going to work out but I'm very
excited for the are emotion guaranteed
top heavy GB at
that's amazing and hopefully and also
the five extra damage on several attacks
hopefully this will make our Musha a
little bit better because he's kind of
on the low tier and I feel bad next up
in this patch for tribute and the only
one for tribute is that friendly-fire
will no longer cause you to drop the
tribute flag anymore nerf the tracking
on many charges and long-range moves
when you queue up for modes the map pool
is decided by which faction war front
the queue is located you can now see
which maps will show up and fix the bug
where you join a match in progress and
gets stuck in the tactical view for the
entire game so those are gonna be the
patches for next week once again I'm
reiterating this four times I do
apologize but just to make sure the full
patch notes are in the description
there's a lot of bug fixes for just
about every character check the
description look for it look it over or
watch it with me it's all good and then
to end the stream they did a little Q&A
like they always do and to summarize
that they're looking to improve the
ranked awards for ranked play in general
to get more people to play it more
because as everyone knows ranked
Dominion really doesn't have too many
people in it nor does ranked duel
anymore like I said they're gonna be
focusing on conquer Berserker ken say in
Highlander for season 5 and as well as
other heroes should be getting similar
treatment but those are the main five
they also have plans for Salvage which
might be implemented in season 5
possibly making it so we can turn that
into steel or any other type of currency
who'll know we won't know yet they're
also working on a solution for the
people that like to back - and avoid
combat especially when they're out of
stamina trust me I've been guilty of it
for the past a week I've been doing it
tons even since the game is started I've
always been doing it and that guy is
going to be the end of the video today
if you guys did enjoy please be sure to
leave a like subscribe before me to for
honor I cover the dev stream recaps the
news the leaks the discussions all the
informational signed a for honor my two
most recent videos are gonna be popping
up on screen oh I also forgot to also
make sure to hit that bell next to the
subscribe buttons you can keep up to
date of my streams my community posts
and my new videos so you never miss out
on those thank you guys for sticking
around I know it's been a couple weeks
since the dev streams have bit since
they have been vacant but like I said
we're gonna be pushing out the dev
stream this week next week we're
supposed to be getting some new info
especially on season 5
let me guys know what you guys think
about season 5 especially with the no
heroes but hopefully it works out either
way thank y'all for watching have a
great day
and peace out